named dark edge broadsword weapon soul
katana its flames grow the more Souls it
claims favorite band Slipknot favorite
movie The Dark Knight Friends Shaggy 2
dope shrek pewdiepie enemies Justin
Bieber well my heart is a black
tormented hole of emptiness how are you
Oh Oh Sonic oh good old Sonic we're not
so different you and I Sonic we've gone
through our faces let's just put it
let's just put it put it put it the day
there's a new Sonic game coming out and
I thought in the spirit of that we would
take a trip back back in the past before
this became this why are we still here
now apparently Sonic started off through
a drawing competition and he wasn't the
most favorable character but they they
created Sega created Sonic because they
wanted to compete with Nintendo which
was the Big Shot console at the time
Sonic even had a sexy woman girlfriend
Sonic was the coolest
hey kid what you doing watching this
stupid film don't you want to have fun
playing Sega sigga sigga sigga shooting
Oh
[Music]
well it worked sega took over nintendo
with which the creation of Sonic
it was so massively popular and by the
time Sonic 2 came out Nintendo was
destroyed no when you buy the Sega
Genesis that comes with Sonic 1 you'll
get Sonic 2 absolutely free
Sonic to handle stubborn stains
embarrassing bald spots no problem it
even slices and dices makes thousands of
julienne fries but wait you can play it
too please free Sonic 2 is a $54.99
value you get 2 Sonic's for the price of
one
Sonic 2 fits easily into any tackle box
made from a space-age polymer plastic
four years of family fun and pets love
it to buy the Sega Genesis that come the
[ __ ] is that face what is that face
these commercial cannot have did they
try and terrify people into buying Sonic
it is because it worked apparently to
come the biggest biggest guy on the
market Mario you know goddamn well done
Sonny well done I remember used to play
Sonic with my dad it was a good time it
was the first console I ever owned it
was the first video game I ever owned
the first console Sonic played it it was
a lot of fun and you frickin Fricks run
let's just say things good things went
south things went south really Sonic 3
came out it was really good sonic
Knuckles oh my god but then something
happened something happened there was
there was an error in the time line
[Music]
sunshine
apparently what happened was the
Japanese team and the American team got
split up and they didn't make any more
Sonic games after Sonic 3 and they try
to fill out the franchise because Sonic
was still big and they made all these
games they made all this games like
Sonic are you frickin Fricks and you
ruined then the good Lord of Jesus
Christ Sonic the Hedgehog and yeah you
know sonic never really came back to us
the loss of Sonic
Sonic's prime it it it hurt a lot of
good people out there okay a lot of
people suffered because their Idol was
ruined their legendary Sonic was
destroyed
and as I'm sure you're aware it's
created one of the one of the most
bizarre fan bases probably probably of
all time anywhere you go it's just weird
it just it just never it just never ends
it just it just keeps on going this is
nothing sexually tensioned about a
hedgehog there's just isn't anything
don't say do you understand the pain you
let sonic go through and the fans they
suffer he lost his mother the man lost
his marbles well arguably the 3d the 3d
genre of video games ruined the sonic
franchise it worked well for Mario
because Super Mario 64 was such a
classic and well done game would you
have a game about going fast you don't
need the other axis you don't need the
extra dimension
and it never transitioned well for Sonic
and it shows why Sonic mania was such a
good game because it kept it to the
basics kept its to its core it kept what
was good about it sometimes less is more
and Sonic is the prime example of that
probably you know Sonic breaks the sound
barrier from his speed but this man just
broke the sound barrier from the pitch
of his voice my god
so the Sonic fandom and how mistreated
Sonic has gotten really created some
some of the weirdest bits of the
Internet I've ever seen Sonic
single-handedly did this have you guys
heard of Christian I don't maybe it's
better if people don't a lot of people
already are familiar but there's this
lovely man look at him he's beautiful
he's a huge fan of Sonic which you can
tell by his stunningly beautiful
necklace and he dresses like a jock
he looks a bit you know what he looks a
bit like Trey Parker the creator of
South Park yes he created this wonderful
webcomic called Sonic the Hedgehog vs.
sonic 2 sonic choo which is a mix of Jew
and Sonic the world's most way past cool
comic Christian made this and he just
have one thing to ask him and in return
just one thing
my name is christian chandler age 22 at
this time i will be 23 our february 24th
2005 may wait for over a year now I've
been trying to attract an 18 to 20 year
old boy friendly girl 18 21 before
February 24 2004 which is this year they
hope the try for over a year to attract
a girl he just wants a girlfriend is
that too much to ask here's this here's
his demands 18 to 24 years old okay fine
boyfriend free seems reasonable
white alright within 20 miles of zip
code and he posted his zip code okay
that's cool under 230 pet caring pretty
cute hopefully a virgin he posted this
in his school with the lowest Sonic chew
thing and you just have to follow the
line to get there
christian clearly has made the best the
best cartoon of all time sonic chew and
it seems only fair that at least he can
get a girlfriend go sonic chew go out
and zap to the extreme so he integrates
himself in the comics which is something
very revolutionary for its time of
course this was done a couple years ago
i will thank you Father
wait it's his child
sonic chewed his child i don't know how
that works
maybe he'd sees him as a father figure
gives Pokemon you just catch them but
then he doesn't have a girlfriend and
there's a lot of missing pieces to this
puzzle people started noticing some
slightly homosexual references in the
Sun it's horrible I shouldn't be
laughing but they they started picking
up on some some things here and there
and they started bullying Christian for
being homosexual Christian responded
whether if I was a homosexual or any
thing like that would I not be having
sex with three women and he had attached
a photo of himself which is gonna be
blurred but he's wearing the medallion
so you know it's him I am straight damn
it I will not be very into any other
disgustingly grotesque direction
I'm straight I'm straight you're the
homeless every last one of you now if
this isn't straight I don't know what
straightest ain't nothing more straight
than thumbing up while you puff it up
BAM all right so this is Christian now
just to keep it clear on the topic I am
a male lesbian intersex transgender you
can google lesbian identified male for
more info on the subject I am sincerely
into women and I am female in my soul
and even posted this yes my love quest
is finally over heart at a hundred
percent with the LGBT color and the back
lovely let's share this bit up a bit
just dance
[Music]